في غضون ذلك قالت وكاله الانبياء
الالمانيه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي قرر زياده
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا بثلاثه
مليارات ونصف المليار يورو جاء ذلك خلال
اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه دولي الاتحاد
الاوروبي في لوكس وكان مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف في
وقت سابق اليوم ان الدول الاعضاء وافقت
على زياده الدعم العسكري الذي تقدمه
لاوكرانيا
عبد الله الشامي عبد الله بالاضافه الى
هذا الدعم الجديد اوكرانيا ما الذي جرى
التباحثه في هذا الاجتماع لوزاره خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي
مع مزراع الخارج
كانت اوكرانيا
الابرز والاقوى في هذا الاجتماع كما هي
العاده في هذه الاجتماعات الشهريه كانت
هناك ايضا نقاشات اخرى حول ما له علاقه
بعقوبات جديده هي الحزمه التاسعه ضد افراد
وكيانات في داخل ايران على خلفيه ما يقول
انها انتهاكات الحقوق الانسان تجري هناك
ثم ايضا جرى النقاش حول الاوضاع ما بين
كوسوفو وصربيا على اثر التوترات الحاصله
هناك منذ مطلع الشهر الجاري ثم ايضا ملف
تونس كان حاضرا كانت هناك او كان هناك
استماع لكل من وزراء خارجيه البرتغال
وبلجيكا اللذان زراء تونس في الشهر الماضي
بناء على طلب الوزراء لتقييم الاوضاع هناك
الاجتماع تقريبا انتهى منذ دقائق وينتظر
ان يدلي المتحدث يدلي الممثل الاعلى
السياسه الخارجيه هل اوروبي جوزيف
بتصريحات صحفيه لكي يجمل ابرز ما تم
التوافق عليه لكن الحديث
الاكبر اليوم الابرز كان حول ما جرى في
روسيا الايام الماضيه وهناك شبه اجماع ما
بين الوزراء الذين تحدثوا اليوم على ان
هذه الحادثه او هذه الاحداث هي فرصه لكي
يؤكد الاتحاد الاوروبي مره اخرى على دعمه
لاوكرانيا وعلى انه يجب كما قال بعض
الوزراء ان يستغل هذه الفرصه التي اثبتت
كما تم الحديث عنه ان النظام في روسيا
يتلقى نتائج عكسيه عكس ما كان يتصور من
هذه الحرب وانه ان ذلك كله يثبت ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي كان موفقا وكان ربما كما
قال بوريل اختار الخيار الاصح عندما قرر
ان دعم اوكرانيا ليس مرتبطا بموارد ولا
بوقت ولا باي من غيرها من التفاصيل ينتظر
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع ايضا ان تعود
اوكرانيا مره اخرى من خلال توصيات الوزراء
على طاوله قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي لكي يقرر
القاده حول ما اذا كانوا يريدون ان يسرعوا
ملف انضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث
اعطيت في مطلع هذا العام صفه مرشح العضويه
وهو امر سنسمع عنه خلال هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي عبد الله الشامي مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من لوكسمبورج شكرا جزيلا لك